what's up guys my name is Colin McNeill
for the score eSports last week exhale o
player and current fortnight's streamer
ninja made mainstream headlines when he
cued with Drake Travis Scott and juju
Smith Schuester breaking a lot of twitch
records in the process now I know you
and I could probably not care less about
the latest celebrity gossip but you got
to admit when someone who's mainstream
famous or just famous in a community
that isn't gaming streams its kind of
hype with that in mind we thought this
would be the perfect opportunity to
bring you the top ten celebrities who
have streamed on Twitch well guys we
decided to start our list off on a high
note for this one with the d-o-double-g
himself Snoop Dogg streaming battle
royale title SOS in January of 2018
[Applause]
smithereens be calm now let me be blunt
here it appears that Snoop Dogg wasn't
actually playing the game so much as he
was watching reacting and controlling
the mic we just hope that doesn't cause
his future streaming career to go up in
smoke
next up on our list Felicia Day is
widely known as one of the Queens of the
Nerds she's most famous for her role as
the producer of the guild a series that
is based off her life as a gamer Felicia
was also a member of the cast of Buffy
the Vampire Slayer and supernatural
among others in recent years Felicia has
built her stream on Twitch playing a
variety of games he's wearing like my
grandpa on her head
like so [ __ ] up including rise of the
Tomb Raider and Dragon Age Inquisition
no no didn't work didn't work shut up
shut up lady take your gravity and shove
it what's going on here
number eight on our list might be the
only member of this top ten that's
actually competed at an eSports event
Heyward has always been an advocate for
eSports and even competed in the IGN pro
league during the NBA lockout in 2011
all right Jordan let's get you into
shape
now what league are you in the NBA Ament
in Starcraft 2 gold when he hits the
rift hey word can be found in the top
lane playing champions like Tryndamere
and out playing his lane opponents like
we see here no way no way R&B and
hip-hop performer t-pain was one of the
first celebrities to make their mark on
overwatch after the game came out the
Bayou ax drank singers on stream antics
are just as hilarious as you'd expect in
a point by yourself he could be found
playing a variety of heroes from junk
rat - Lucio to Hinds oh and now they
brought the [ __ ] rest the [ __ ] on us
and it's our famous DJ producer and
musician deadmau5 comes in at number 6
and he's likely the celebrity who's
taken the biggest dive into Twitch
deadmau5 streams almost every day with a
lot of it lately being pub G one bullet
in a dream one bullet he's also found a
unique way to combine his career with
his twitch personality by streaming
himself working on and creating music of
all the members on this list deadmau5 is
definitely the one most entrenched in
twitch and streaming culture
Oh get [ __ ]
get [ __ ]
drop there I killed him coming in at
number five Quinton Rampage Jackson is a
former UFC light heavyweight champion
and has recently been streaming player
unknowns battlegrounds you guys knock
behind a car Jackson has even been known
to get some winner winner chicken
dinners proving that he can go on a
rampage Lupe Fiasco is the second
hip-hop star to touchdown on our list
the superstar rapper has been a huge
supporter of the fighting game community
for years now and is more than just a
street fighter fan he's a player dude is
what about the video games just
testament to how strong yeah the switch
culture is out here he even allowed
Capcom to use a song from his newest
album for Colin's announcement trailer
his biggest gaming moment was certainly
his show match against Daigo at the
Street Fighter 5 release party this
could be a new career path taking the
third spot on this list is Rick Fox a
true og of the celebrity dive into
eSports and an XM be a player with the
Boston Celtics and Los Angeles Lakers
he's really done it all in eSports from
streaming oh [ __ ]
I got jacked from behind that's a
horrible call Jim echo Fox Jesus to
becoming part owner of echo box Rick Fox
is known for that winning smile and has
really entrenched himself in the scene
over the last few years back in February
Fox dream for the first time with his
son Kyle Thank You Kyle taking the
coveted number-two spot on this list Mia
Khalifa has quickly become one of the
most notable online personalities out
there the former adult actress turned
Washington Sports Personality and
complex talk show host has recently
started doing IRL streams he liked that
one spot what the [ __ ] am i doing
she streamed herself doing everything
from cooking to hanging out on the couch
playing NBA 2k well I bet you didn't see
this one coming our number one is last
week's record-setting stream featuring
ninja and rappers Drake Travis Scott and
Pittsburgh Steelers wide receiver juju
Smith Schuster after initially stumbling
to get their comms going the stream
quickly smashed twitch viewership
records and got as high as six hundred
and thirty thousand concurrent smashing
dr. disrespects previous record of the
388,000
my dick forget it cash in what was
arguably one of the most iconic moments
in Twitch's history the six God bless
viewers all over the world with some
memorable extreme highlights
I'd like to dub this particular stream
views from tilted towers let's go baby
oh well guys that's our list but if your
favorite celebrity streamer did not make
our top ten just flame us in the
comments or something okay thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button